[Music]  i was sent to find you  there's a door in front of you  on the other side is something i could  never imagine  they're gonna take the house next month  i'm always working  molly has no one  i saw something  it freaked me out  i was sent to find you  i'm talking to someone from another  planet  so am i  do you have anyone a family children  [Music]  they are waiting for me  if they survived  my planet is dying  earth is on the same  trajectory can you  help me  you are a scientist  you have the potential for all things  [Music]  i need to know where he's from and i  need to know what he's doing here  [Music]  they know what you are  [Music]  go  take him now  i brought you here to finish what i  started  this is how we all survived  [Music]  you